okay you ready let's work out the
derivative okay so let's do the inside
first now that is a bit messy that's 1
minus x squared to the power of 1/2
ok so let's give it a go shall we what
minus x squared to the air path let's do
this so this is chain rule of chain rule
okay yeah I heard you like calculus so
the inside of the inside function is
minus 2x all right that's the inside yes
ok now I'll do the outside of that to
the hub and walk the foot and then I'm
going to reduce the power by 1 so that's
1 minus x squared is that check out that
like ok I've done the inside there's the
outside now I'll do the outside outside
which is sine emos okay so that should
be 1 over the square root of 1 minus u
squared 1 minus u squared ok no problem
good let's tell you something there is a
bit of a disaster at the moment the 2 in
the half they care for so I'm gonna get
minus X the top this is gonna come down
the bottom right yeah and now I have
this so 1 minus 1 0 minus minus x
squared positive extra
ok now we'd we just did this right what
am I gonna do on the next line what am I
gonna do on the next line ok I need my
absolute value yet for this this guy
right so minus X or absolute value okay
so now I'll get my branches ok now you
tell me what are the domain restrictions
on T to the raters
what's the lefthand pot it's based on
what's inside the absolute value right
so I'm gonna say here 4x is less than 0
okay what happens when X is less than 0
what does the absolute value become yeah
minus X right so this is gonna be minus
X or minus X so those will cancel right
which leaves me with 1 ok now for the
other side that I made absolute value of
X just equals x without the minus sign
right so minus x over x equals minus 1
ok now at this point so bail should be
read right we've just gone through all
the effort to differentiate this and
then we landed on these two which we
surely recognize right what's this the
derivative of this is the river sign of
us
what's this derivative cos inverse huh
ok now what does that mean what what is
this gonna tell us about the graph right
now let me take a step back ok if I ask
you to graph this right before you did
the derivative what can you tell me
about this graph is it anything you can
tell you out this graph without calculus
anything at all
okay so there's the restriction on the
domain namely it's between minus one and
one that's good do we know anything else
about it
I think it can be cool I don't think it
has any asymptotes does this does this
function have any kind of symmetry does
it have any symmetry what kind of
symmetry does it have think about it
thinking about thinking other pieces
right sine inverse does that have
symmetry sine inverse it has odd
symmetry right on its own anyway
what about this what kind of symmetry
does that have this is an even function
hmm are you taking an even function
and you apply an odd function to it what
do you think will happen do you get no
symmetry do you get odd symmetry or do
you get even symmetry think big yeah yes
what kind of sushi yeah well this is
this is not a legit sort of proof right
but it'll at least help us think through
okay this is hard because their
functions were not definitely real okay
so let's take some functions we are
familiar with take an even function like
saying X square we know that that's even
okay
what's an odd function that you know a
lot about how about X cubed x cube so
you take an even function and you apply
an odd function to it what kind of
symmetry does that have
sorry there's a dense it's another even
function right you could have switched
this around and you would've seen okay
that's right that's right it's not
that's right it's not x squared times X
cubed it's x squared cubed which is what
I'm having here function of a function
okay this is an even function okay now
you should have already known that right
cuz look look at the derivatives you see
you see their opposite to each other on
opposite sides of domain okay question
oh well see ya be tricky you gotta be
careful here right multiplication and
and actually don't know what the word is
I should go look this up but when you
make a the difference between this and
this right what's the difference between
them this is a function times a function
this is a function of a function right
so there is a difference because that's
odd and this is even okay let me come
back I'm so running out of time they try
and work out what this thing is
okay let's take a step back right sign
in this is something it's kind of like
an angle right sine inverse or 3/4 or
sine inverse of 12 13 or whatever so
stay with me I want you to remember this
if Y is an angle right this is true
isn't it this is just this is just the
paper going on in it you know well okay
so I'm gonna take it and I'm gonna use
it over here okay for reasons that will
become clear in a second I'm going to
leave that cause but I am gonna put this
into where Y is so I'm gonna get sine
squared off this plus cos squared y
equals 1 okay what can I do with this
don't forget this side squared right
what it really means is sign of that oh
what's this thing equal to I will do
that in a second but I think I need to
deal with this first right because this
is kind of a mess right don't forget I
really exist in this domain
what's it equal to it's just sorry wait
no Mississippi square one minus x
squared right because remember sine is
sine inverse whatever is equal to that
within this domain yes okay so here's
what I got
let's see if I can erase and finish this
right what's cos squared equal to keep
it x squared right so cos y equals x
right wrong that's right there's a plus
month now where's the plus - where's the
plus - it's actually equal to the
absolute value of x right where's the
plus - think about this okay cos Y is
equal to X for what domain think think
positive positive it's when execrating 0
right
okay so for this I'm getting close
inverse of X X is positive for the other
side of the domain when it's negative
okay cause why isn't equal to X what's
it equal to negative X so Y is equal to
cos inverse of negative x right now you
tell me what's the difference between
these two this matches up exactly what
we're expecting you right there's a
difference there is a difference X is
greater than zero that's this that
checks out that sorry this is the beauty
of that fine right what does this look
like what happens when you slap a minus
sign on the X what difference does it
make yeah that's right if I want to give
you this right and I slap the minus sign
on the Y which way would it flip it were
to flip this way right so that's why you
get the frown but if I put the minus
sign of the X it doesn't flip this way
vertically it lives this way
horizontally right so here's my shape
okay 4x is greater 0 I'm gonna get cos
inverse what's it look like over here
that all right what does it look like on
the other side it looks like the flipped
version it looks like that okay so I'm
gone
I've ran out of time we'll have a think
about integration tomorrow